we are constantly surrounded by
information in today's digital world but
not all of it is accurate we rely on
data to gauge whether something is true
or false but we rarely see this data in
its raw form you can imagine how rows
and rows of numbers could be very
confusing to interpret because of this
we usually use a method called data
visualization to present patterns and
trends in data more easily data
visualization is the translation of data
into visual representations like charts
and graphs to communicate the data's
significance however while this method
simplifies the process of understanding
data it can also be used to bend the
truth and misrepresent information one
such technique is the process of
cherry-picking data this name comes from
the idea that if a cherry picker only
picks the healthiest and rapist fruits
it could lead an observer to wrongly
assume that all of the cherries on the
tree are healthy even though that isn't
the case this has been observed in the
veterinary industry where vets are more
likely to report only the positive
trials when testing the responses of
dogs cats horses cattle and sheep to
novel drugs especially when the studies
have been funded by pharmaceutical
companies these practices aren't just
limited to pets and livestock industry
trials of drugs for humans such as
antidepressants were reported to be much
more likely to show positive results
than government funded studies of the
same drugs another way of using data
visualizations to manipulate information
is the use of cumulative data instead of
annual data cumulative data means adding
each successive input in the data set up
so that the graph will always be rising
annual data on the other hand would show
the data for each individual here which
could be increasing or decreasing this
method is often used by companies to
make their sales and figures appear
larger than they actually are
date of vis manipulations are commonly
used in politics to make a particular
party or candidate look more favorable
for example pie charts are commonly used
to represent numeric proportion like
showing which candidates people are most
likely to vote for but consider if
participants in the survey are allowed
to vote for more than one candidate then
you could end up with a pie chart where
the sector's add up to over 100 percent
this is inaccurate because pie charts
are meant to show proportions of a whole
where each group is distinct and can
make it appear as though a larger
percentage of voters have chosen that
particular candidate a better
visualization would be a Venn diagram to
show how many votes each candidate
received and where they overlap lastly
let's look at bar graphs bar graphs can
misrepresent data through a manipulation
of the scale of the y-axis for example a
politician might want to exaggerate how
high school graduation rates have
increased during their tenure you can
see how the difference between 75% and
80% can seem far more significant when
viewed on a y-axis that begins at 50
verses 0 from politicians
misrepresenting data to appeal to voters
to scientists cherry-picking data to
exaggerate their research progress date
of misrepresentation can bend the truth
in extreme ways however now that you've
seen how data can be manipulated you can
be more wary of the information you
receive and thus make well informed
choices whether it's choosing between
brands candidates or reliefs
you